hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
this is Forbes Magazine on the 14th of
February 2023 the title of this
particular article reads America's best
banks an entity by the name of Silicon
Valley Bank was ranked number 20 and has
been on the list for five years in a row
founded in 1983 svb was the 16th largest
bank in the United States and had over
209 billion dollars in assets yet in a
few short weeks the bank would go up in
Flames over the course of a couple of
days
Valley Banks collapse set off a Panic
not seen since the days of the financial
meltdown of 2008. the collapse of
Silicon Valley Bank is causing shock
waves across the entire business world
with the FDIC now in control customers
can access up to 250 thousand dollars on
Monday but as ABC's Jaclyn Lee explains
that's not enough for many companies
left struggling to manage their finances
this weekend clients of Silicon Valley
Bank are scrambling and imploring the
federal government to step in to help
recover uninsured deposits over
250 thousand dollars it's the largest
bank failure since the financial crisis
of 2008. the crash created a Cascade of
events some smaller Regional Banks lost
the majority of their valuation and
another has since collapsed companies
such as roadblocks VOX media and a whole
host of Silicon Valley startups are
scrambling to find the cash to pay their
employees meanwhile the UK government is
at work trying to minimize the effects
of the crash and at the same time the
rest of the economy is trying to figure
out what the long-term consequences of
This Disaster may be
this is the largest bank failure since
2008 and the second largest in history
but how did a bank go from making the
list of the best banks to bankrupt in
less than a month what happens next is
this the start of another financial
crisis
maybe not but there are some risks what
everyone seems to have missed in this
story is that it's more of a cautionary
tale of mismanagement incompetent and
political lobbying the bank's parent
company its CEO and CFO are all being
sued for fraud and the CEO lobbied
Congress to remove the very laws that
would have prevented this crash in the
first place this whole thing is a crazy
story so let's get into it
[Music]
you are watching cold fusion TV
to understand the consequences of this
crash we need to know how it started
Silicon Valley Bank or svb was no
ordinary Bank it was the go-to
institution for venture capital and Tech
startups the bank enjoyed a healthy
period of growth during the 2020
pandemic low interest rates and
excessive money printing from the U.S
federal reserve caused the tech sector
to Boom money was easy and investors
were generous
at the time startups were able to raise
money easily due to cheap credit once
the companies got that money they needed
somewhere to store it this is where
Silicon Valley Bank comes in
svb was very popular among Founders in
fact nearly 50 percent of all United
States startups have some deposits in
Silicon Valley Bank
in 2021 svb saw a massive influx and
deposit from around 61 billion at the
end of 2019 to around 189 billion at the
end of 2021.
now svb wanted to make a larger profit
from all of this cash that they were
suddenly sitting on
a safe investment would be long-term
bonds these are usually seen as safer
than stocks and provide a steady return
here's why when interest rates are low
newly issued bonds pay lower interest
rates or returns making existing
long-term bonds that pay higher more
attractive this leads to an increase in
demand for these bonds and an increase
in their price so whoever's holding
these long-term bonds makes money svb
saw this situation and invested 80
billion dollars of their tech company
deposits in long-term bonds and other
securities
they could then turn around and pay
depositors a lower rate the difference
between the higher rates from their
long-term bonds and the cost of paying
low rates for their deposits would be
their profit this Arrangement Works
particularly well even if some clients
decided to withdraw sooner the bank can
simply sell the bonds and get the
liquidity necessary to pay back the
depositor but what happens when everyone
wants to withdraw their money all at
once
Silicon Valley Bank was about to find
out
as we covered in a previous episode
about the 2008 crisis and its aftermath
that still affects us today the
post-crisis market isn't used to a high
interest rate environment and higher
interest rates could create risks in
vulnerable areas of the financial system
the risk management team of svb ignored
this risk but more on this later
problems for svb began brewing in late
2021 in the United States inflation
began to rise
usually when this happens the U.S
federal reserve would increase interest
rates to slow the economy and counteract
the inflation but this time the U.S
federal reserve stood by and did nothing
for a while they told everyone that
inflation was transitory this turned out
to be completely wrong and when the FED
realized their mistake they had to raise
interest rates very quickly to make up
for lost time
this Whiplash in higher rates didn't
allow time for the market to adjust
meanwhile at svb their investing
environment began to flip on its head as
the interest rates Rose the newly issued
bonds began to pay higher interest rates
and this made the older long-term bonds
less attractive to investors this
resulted in a decline in demand causing
their prices to fall svb still owned
tens of billions worth of these
long-term bonds so they were a Sitting
Duck for risk
by the end of 2022 there were 15 billion
dollars in unrealized losses from the
fall in long-term bond prices
now normally this isn't an issue as if
svb held onto these bonds until maturity
they wouldn't lose anything but this was
not a normal time in a higher interest
rate environment technology startups
were struggling to get financing as
credit began to dry up these tech
companies needed to dip into their cash
to fund their operations
with startups being the main client for
svb the deposit started to slow down
falling from 189 billion at the end of
2021 to 173 billion at the end of 2022
with every large withdrawal svb had to
sell some of their long-term bonds to
cover the transaction
for some time the bank had enough
liquidity to deal with these withdrawals
As Time passed the depositors continued
to leave on March 8 2023 svb made a
bombshell announcement they were selling
off their entire liquid Bond portfolio
worth over 21 billion until this point
the falling bond prices were only
unrealized losses that is losses only on
paper but once sold svb took a 1.8
billion loss in the sale
to recoup some losses management decided
to raise some Capital while this seemed
like a logical choice this was a grave
error from management the timing could
not have been worse just days before
silvergate a small crypto Focus Bank
failed due to a similar issue although
this failure had more to do with the
exposure to the overall crypto market
and FTX in particular but the root cause
was the same the bank had a lot of
assets which had lost their value due to
Rising interest rates and when
withdrawals in the crypto Market began
to happen they had no choice but to sell
those assets each sale of the asset was
at a lower price than when they bought
it
once the loss is powered up there was no
turning back investors assumed that svb
was going down the same path
Fierce over insolvency issues quickly
spread and this resulted in svb stock
losing close to 60 percent of its value
in one day as all of this unfolded many
Venture Capital firms advised the
founders of startups to pull their money
out of svb further exacerbating the
problem by the end of March 9th
customers have withdrawn 42 billion
dollars leaving the bank with a negative
cash balance about negative 958 million
the withdrawals were so heavy that it
ended up crashing the bank's internal
system only creating more fear
depositors had a reason to panic in the
United States under the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation or FDIC the U.S
government only guarantees refunds up to
250 000 now the thing is being a
technology company focused Bank 97 of
svb deposits exceeded this number
the value of Silicon Valley Bank shares
continued to be destroyed until its
trading was suspended on the morning of
March 10th they tried to raise capital
and failed and then by midday on March
10th the bank started to look for a
company to bail them out and no one
wanted to touch them nobody knew the
extent of the problem so it was a risk
this culminated in svb being shut down
by the FDIC
this all happened on March 10th less
than two days after the crisis started
this was a spectacular failure on the
side of management they failed to adjust
to a rising interest rate environment
and yes the U.S federal reserve did get
it wrong when they stated that inflation
was only transitory but svb should have
had a contingency plan just in case
inflation did stick around
if any of you watching work in Risk
Management especially in banking I'd
love to hear from you in the comments
Below on what a contingency plan could
have been it seems that as soon as
interest rates started Rising the bank
could have began to offload their
long-term treasuries and exchange them
for bonds yielding higher interest to
minimize their losses instead it seems
that they waited and sold all of their
liquid long-term bonds at once after the
value had already fallen
as Bill Ackman States quote Silicon
Valley Bank Senior Management made a
basic mistake they invested short-term
deposits in longer term fixed-rate
assets
so how could management do such a thing
well the story gets a bit Wilder the
more that you look
as people began to dig deeper into this
crash some new information painted a
very worrisome picture the chief risk
officer for Silicon Valley Bank
hightailed and left in April of 2022 and
wasn't replaced until January of 2023
this meant that the bank had no Chief
risk officer for eight months this was
precisely at the time when the downward
feedback loop was accelerating from the
higher interest rates
just when the bank's portfolios needed
to be rebalanced to account for higher
interest rates there was no one to
oversee the process in other words the
bank was a plane without a pilot during
a storm just shocking but it doesn't end
there worse yet Silicon Valley Bank CAO
was the CFO of none other than Lehman
Brothers at the time of its crash
and you can't help but laugh at how
ridiculous this next part is the Federal
Reserve Bank of San Francisco was in
charge of supervising svb and guess he
was on the board the CEO of svb Greg
Becker
Greg was promptly heated from the board
after the crash interestingly the CEO
CFO and CMO of the bank sold a combined
4.4 million dollars of company stock
just weeks before svb's decline an SEC
filing stated that the sale of the
shares was quote automated and quote
pre-planned but it remains unclear if
there was some foreknowledge of the
collapse further to this the bank's
employee received their annual bonuses
ranging from 12 000 to 140 000 only
hours before the bank's official crash I
can't allege implications of wrongdoing
but there may be a chance that the guys
at the top knew something was coming
right now svb is being sued for fraud by
shareholders the lawsuit states that the
company failed to disclose how Rising
interest rates could leave the bank
particularly susceptible to a bank run
a crash of svb was indeed unique a
combination of rapid growth bad risk
management low interest rates excessive
exposure to only one market and large
deposits with no FDIC Insurance have all
led us to this point
but is this the start of something
bigger for the financial system is it a
Lehman moment
it may very well have been a Lehman
moment for regional Banks as they have
similar characteristics to svb their
clients are businesses they operate in a
very limited number of fields and they
all have some exposure to unrealized
losses in this higher interest rate
environment
because of this the stocks of First Bank
Republic Western Alliance Bancorp and
Westpac Bancorp and other Regional banks
have all seen large declines
some as much as 66 in a day many hedge
funds have also started to short sell
yeah worst week since 2020 last week
John and this week is not starting out
on a better note despite the fact that
depositors of both Silicon Valley Bank
and Signature Bank are going to be made
whole and the FED has announced this new
bank term lending facility that is going
to lend to Banks an extremely favorable
rates that is not helping the regional
Banks this morning clearly there is
still fear out there about this
spreading elsewhere just take a look at
the shares of First Republic down 65
percent here at the opening bell this is
on top of a 33 percent loss last week a
week ago this was a 122 dollar stock
this morning it is trading at 28 a share
that is how brutal this white powder has
been John and it's elsewhere in the
regional Banks as well Pac West Western
Alliance the falls and the stock prices
were so drastic that the trading of a
slew of these Banks had to be halted
okay so this next part is key right at
this moment the rest of the banking
system seems to be largely unaffected as
one Analyst at Barclays Road quote
deposit pressure is the greatest for
smaller Banks including regionals Global
banks have more diverse funding sources
and therefore are less vulnerable to
that risk
that being said Bank of America does
have large exposure to long-term bonds
that are planned to be held to maturity
though if they don't sell and actually
hold these bonds to maturity this
shouldn't be a problem
many are comparing this situation to
that of the 2008 financial crisis yet
this is quite different during that time
some of the largest banks in the U.S all
failed simultaneously and they had much
bigger issues to deal with
these Banks had sizable Investments and
assets that overnight became worthless
the assets that are responsible for the
crash of svb are not worthless in fact
far from it they're backed by the US
government and if held to maturity in
theory they're not going to lose any
value
the problem for svb is that they sold
all of these bonds early and realized
those losses tried to raise funds to
cover those losses and that triggered a
panic
another difference resides in the fact
that the banks in 2008 had huge leverage
issues in the case of Lehman Brothers
for example The Leverage exceeded 30
times the underlying asset in other
words a decline of three to five percent
in those assets meant that Lehman
Brothers was completely bankrupt and
lastly the big banks have a far greater
degree of diversification than Regional
Banks this means that they can withstand
liquidity shocks more easily as
generally not every single sector gets
impacted at the same time
not only this but the bigger banks will
probably benefit from the collapse of
regional Banks depositors may move their
money from Regional Banks to larger
institutions and if there are more bank
failures the larger Banks can simply
gobble up the healthy parts for pennies
on the dollar
does this mean that the risk of a
financial crisis is non-existent well
not really while the current Financial
system is very different from the one in
2008 there is still a chance that this
may be the first crack in the Fabrics of
the current Financial system
as of December 2022 the total unrealized
losses for the whole banking system was
close to 620 billion
if Panic spreads too much many small
banks will go down as a result creating
a cascading effect that would cause the
rest of the economy to wobble the
Federal Reserve and the financial
sectors of the US government have
recognized this and have come up with a
solution which we'll get to shortly
the industry that will feel the most
pain is going to be the tech sector svb
quote was the lifeblood of the tech
ecosystem States rokana a congressman
from California's 17th District tens of
thousands of startups rely on them to
pay their day-to-day operations
including staff you see unlike
traditional businesses
many of these tech companies have
negative cash flows the only way that
they can pay their expenses is by
raising capital
after the capital has been obtained they
store it and use it until the next raise
if you take that stored money away very
quickly many of these firms start to
fail
several firms aren't going to be able to
pay their employees and if there's
further delays and when the money is
returned a huge wave of layoffs and then
eventually bankruptcies will follow
Etsy had to delay their seller payouts
the streaming company Roku held a
quarter of its cash reserves in svb
Roblox rocket lab Circle Fox Media and
Vimeo are among countless companies
affected the CEO of Y combinator Gary
tan puts it best quote this is an
extinction level event for startups and
will set back their Innovation by 10
years or more
confidence in the finance industry has
been shaken U.S banks lost a combined
100 billion and 50 billion for the
valuation of European Banks
on the 13th of March Joe Biden had to
reassure the United States population
look the bottom line is this Americans
can rest assured that our banking system
is safe your deposits are safe let me
also assure you we will not stop at this
we'll do whatever is needed the
situation also spreads to the UK
the bank of England was looking for ways
to minimize the damage the United
Kingdom also had an arm of Silicon
Valley bank then on March 13th HSBC
bought the stricken UK entity for a
measly one pound or one US dollar and 21
cents at the height of the chaos 200 UK
firms confirmed that they weren't going
to be able to pay their staff on the
other side of the world Chinese startups
also reported issues accessing their
funds svb was especially popular among
Chinese biotech startups
as one founder explained quote we tried
everything Friday morning but it was
already too late the transfer is still
processing it's very crazy we didn't
think this could happen
for Chinese groups their ecosystem was
already damaged by beijing's Tech
Crackdown and covid-19 pandemic controls
not to mention the rising geopolitical
tensions with Washington
so in all of this where were the
regulators
well being lobbied apparently back in
2015 svb CEO begged lawmakers to exempt
banks with assets less than 250 billion
from the tough supervision and
regulations of the Dodd-Frank Act for
those who remember my 2008 episode this
act was put into place to stop another
financial crisis
in 2018 a bill was passed that weakened
this act and Greg Becker got his wish
so omarova professor of law at Cornell
University who testified before the
Senate against relaxing regulations for
smaller Banks said that the 2018 Bill
quote should not have passed
and he was spot on
the dust has only just started to settle
Silicon Valley Bank is now under FDIC
control and the FDIC has since moved svb
deposits to a newly formed holding bank
and named Tim mayopolis a CEO
on March 12 2023 another Regional Bank
Signature Bank collapsed meanwhile
Signature Bank marks the third largest
bank failure in U.S history seeing more
possible bank failures on the horizon
the Federal Reserve had to do something
unprecedented they announced the
creation of a bank term funding program
to shore up liquidity for other at-risk
Banks they're allowing the affected
Banks to sell their long-term bonds and
securities to the FED without a loss in
another announcement on the same day the
treasury Federal Reserve and FDIC stated
that all depositors even the uninsured
ones will be made whole without the
expenditure of taxpayer money some
Financial commentators have said that
this is an inflationary move
a lot of regional Banks who use the same
style of banking as svb saw worried
depositors piling up outside to get
their money out
the fed and U.S government had to do
these drastic moves to avoid Bank runs
and a Cascade of bankruptcies
nobody is a fan of government-assisted
bailouts but this is a tough situation
as Simon Johnson an economist at MIT who
previously served as the chief Economist
of the IMF says quote all choices are
bad choices you don't want to extend
this kind of bailout to people but if
you aren't doing that you face a run of
really big and really hard to predict
proportions
[Music]
this is the largest banking failure
since the financial crisis if the fed's
creation of the bank term funding
program isn't as smooth as promised or
takes too long for consequences for the
companies around the us could be
devastating even though I think the
Federal Reserve does have some blame for
the background macroeconomic situation
they did need to do something
further to this if the Federal Reserve
reverses course and starts cutting
interest rates inflation could ramp up
again causing even more Havoc they're
stuck between a rock and a hard place
raise rights destroy the economy cut
rates also destroy the economy
with Silicon Valley holding 50 percent
of U.S VC backed startups as customers
65 000 startups would be affected by the
collapse even if the government does
succeed in making each depositor whole
it's a sad time for the tech sector as
confidence has been shaken the nightmare
of being locked out of company cash
delays in paying staff and countless
Administration issues we'll leave a scar
in summary this is a story of rapidly
changing market conditions risk
management failure and lobbying but
zooming out even further this is exactly
the kind of risk I was talking about in
my 2008 episode in the third section of
that video I talked about how unhealthy
this economy has been ever since the
crash the post-crisis economy has been
built on a scaffolding of easy money and
low interest rates when these conditions
reverse we'll start to see that weak
scaffolding start to shake what happened
here is proof right in our faces it will
be the weaker and badly managed sectors
of the economy that start to show at
first but what happens after that is
anyone's guess you should definitely
watch that episode if you haven't
already I think you'll get a lot out of
it so this svb story is still unfolding
we can only wait and see what the longer
term impacts will be
so that's about it for me thanks for
watching if you did enjoy this take a
look around on the channel there's
plenty of interesting stuff on here
alright my name is Togo and you have
been watching cold fusion and I'll catch
you again soon for the next episode
cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
what's going on
cold fusion it's new thinking